[Music]
Yolanda Jennifer Lopez is ready for a
ring from Alex Rodriguez Alex are you
watching hello no pressure no aggressive
the 48 year old stopped by The Tonight
Show Starring Jimmy Fallon on Wednesday
and opened up about her new Spanish
single LMAO LMAO means the ring which is
all about ladies who are ready to get an
engagement ring from their man
definitely about that it is but I felt
like it was kind of like something that
all women kind of get to a point where
they say they're like okay what's up
good everything's great what's going on
it's so nice my favorite Mike yes
JLo who has been married three times
noted that she doesn't think it takes
long to know if your partner is the one
you know exactly know just like you
being like scared and whatever I know I
walk don't go by me I want to do but it
wasn't all ring talk the best fastest
dancer wins okay wait a minute I have
questions as you know I'm competitive
Lopez also broke it down on the dance
floor with Fallon busting out fast moves
to slow jams in a dance-off
[Music]
[Applause]